hello everybody and welcome back to a
new series that I have started on
titanfall 2 where I'd go through all 6
Titans in titanfall 2 and I explained to
you their weapons their personal gadgets
their counters and then you form your
own opinion whether you want to play as
them or not today's episode we're going
to be talking about Ronin
Ronan is a hit and run Titan for the
pilots who are quick on their feet they
will excel with this Titan dealing
damage to unexpected enemies and
singling out ty into straight from the
pack combining his speed with the arc
wave to slow Titans to and make him a
force to be reckoned with but that's
enough about him let's start with his
arsenal Ronan's primary weapon is a
projectile shotgun with a wide spread
called lead wall able to kill a pilot
from a medium distance in one shot if
they are foolish enough to fight with
him he also has an arc wave which flows
in damages enemies who come into his
path a sword block which blocks 90%
damage against him a phase shift which
allows him to quickly teleport in and
out of sticky situations to get the
surprise on the enemy and finally the
sword core in which Ronan whips out his
sword and hacks and slashes at enemies
in his path
now that the weapons have been talked
about let's look at his kid and for
Ronan's gadgets he has for the ricochet
round which bounces the lead walls ammo
off of walls the thunderstorm which
gives ronan to arc waves temporal
anomaly which recharges phase-shift
faster and highlander which extends the
sword core every kill he achieves next
is counters ronan loves enemy titans
when they're by themselves because by
using arc wave and comboing with the
phase shift will kill an opposing Titan
instantly and they won't even have a
chance to see what happened but due to
his small health Ronan hates when he
gets double-teamed so how do you use
Ronan in a fight it's very simple always
remember that you have a low health and
you can't take on more than one by
yourself so group up with a buddy or
pick them off one at a time others it's
time for you to form your own opinion
and whether you like Ronan as a Titan or
not
that is up to you and if you found your
answer leave it in the comments below
I'm curious to see other than that guys
like liked the video comment whether you
like Ronan or not and subscribe if
you're new because I still have four
more Titans to do if you missed my last
video I did tone I'll leave a annotation
on the top of the screen for you to
click on my previous video other than
that guys you know like comment
subscribe all that good stuff you know
and have a good day guys peace
you